pour améliorer les voyez monsieur le
premier ministre c'est aujourd'hui
l'anniversaire de la sécurité sociale
qui a 70 ans
cette sécurité sociale si appréciée des
français mais qu'il considère comme un
système devenu complexe opaque et même
inégalitaire alors que les français ont
dépensé 7 115 milliards d'euros en 2013
pour sûr près leur politique familiale
leur retraite et se soigner le 24
septembre votre ministre de la santé a
présenté le plfss 2016 en 1945
l'heure est à la solidarité mais qu'en
est il aujourd'hui
vous avez le choix de vous en prendre
aux familles aux professionnels de santé
pour mémoire aucun courage pour vous
attaquer à la fraude sociale
cette fraude qui s'élevait en 2013 à
plus de 636 millions d'euros soit
l'équivalent de ce que vous prenez aux
familles
et depuis silence on taxe votre projet
de loi devait rassembler les
professionnels de santé
votre ministre aveuglé par son idéologie
a réussi l'exploit de faire l'unanimité
contre elle des cliniques qui souffrent
des laboratoires qui s'externalise des
pharmacies en faillite des infirmières
épuisées et des médecins en grève en
minimisant le mouvement de grève des
médecins qui se révolte contre l'état
tease à sion de la médecine libérale
voulait méprisé par idéologie vous avez
fait de la généralisation du tiers
payant un étendard c'était inutile
puisque les populations qui en avait
besoin ont bénéficié déjà
de plus la réforme annie vous organisez
le désengagement de l'assurance maladie
obligatoire en faisant peser le poids
financier sur des entreprises chésa
exemple et en oubliant les plus fragiles
à savoir ceux qui ne sont ni salarié ni
bénéficiaires des minima sociaux
mais peut-être que ces français là ne
vous intéresse pas
crise économique démographie
vieillissante déficits records vous
étouffer la sécurité sociale qui a du
mal à souffler ses bougies commémorer
c'est bien mais comme l'a rappelé le
président des républicains
une véritable refondation du modèle
social économique s'impose alors soyez
courageux pour son anniversaire
réconcilier les français la sécurité
sociale
merci madame doyer la parole est à
madame la secrétaire d'état chargée de
la famille de l'enfance et des personnes
âgées d'autonomie madame le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
mesdames les députés
peut-être qu'en cette journée
effectivement du 70e anniversaire de la
sécurité aux siens vous pourriez avoir
des mots plus heureux à l'égard de la
sécurité sociale votre intervention
n'était que critiquent votre attachement
à cette institution n'est pas crédible
n'est pas crédible tant vous en parlais
mal étant vous cherchez en éloigner les
français mais eux ils sont
particulièrement attachés et je vous
prie d'abord d'excuser l'absence de
marisol qui est actuellement justement
en train de célébrer 70 ans
alors vous nous parlez la sécurité
sociale et de son état aujourd'hui
madame permettez-moi d'abord de vous
dire que ce gouvernement fait vivre la
sécurité sociale d'abord en retrait sans
ses comptes le déficit a été réduit de
20% depuis 2012 le régime dirks part à
léquilibre ça n'était pas arrivé depuis
dix ans les chiffres sont là les
résultats son fils sont visibles nous
n'avons procédé contrairement à vous
quand vous diriger ce pays a aucun des
remboursements nous protégeons le niveau
de soin de tous les français et nous
assurons l'accès le plus large à la sens
et nous modernisons la sécurité sociale
nous la protégeons nous la défendons y
compris contre vous merci madame lamy